you can't have those two at the same
time the actual reality is that it's
neither of those yeah that's right it's
neither of those and it's Christianity
as Christianity took hold it integrated
the things it could integrate it it it
it it kind of let fall to the side the
things that couldn't be integrated and
it it ended up with a a world that was
based on the ancient Pagan World in
terms of a lot of the forms but moving
using its meaning pointed towards God
and towards Christ you know
yeah
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
World hello everyone I am uh happy to be
back with Father Andrew it's been a
while since we've had a discussion and
so we felt like this would be a great
time to uh to catch up with some of the
things that we're doing Father Andrew
has been publishing a a wonderful
podcast called The Wolf on the cross
Which documents his visits to Lithuania
and exploration of of Lithuania as this
this amazing Center where Orthodoxy
thrived where Catholicism is there and
that is actually what we're going to
talk about so Father Andrew had the idea
of looking at how the church has dealt
with the question of its encounter with
other religious Traditions you know the
the opposition the the compromise also
bringing in all of these types of things
so I'm looking forward to our discussion
Father Andrew thanks for thanks for
meeting with me again thank you very
much for uh agreeing to talk to me I I
think this is a really interesting topic
that does not get a lot of press in our
very polarized days yeah and for you
also this whole uh Adventure in
Lithuania is also a very
personal uh encounter like it's a it's a
personal Journey let's say it is um I
just came came back a few weeks ago from
my second visit there and um just to
show how personal it is one of the
things I got to do in the second visit
was I visited the small town that my
great-grandfather was from where I had
been before but this time I actually get
to go inside the Catholic church that is
the one Church in that town basically
everybody in the town belongs to that
church the pastor of that church is the
pastor of the Town yeah which is hard
for us who live in the west to imagine
that um but he gave us a very long long
and beautiful tour and one of the things
I got to do while I was there is I
actually got to touch the baptismal font
that my great-grandfather was baptized
in 140 years ago and I got to stand in
the place where my great great
grandparents were married um 160 years
ago um or however many it was but uh
yeah so it's extremely personal and now
I've made a number of of friends that
are there that I talk with pretty much
every day and and
um uh so yeah it is it is um something
very very close to my heart so tell us a
little bit about what because I I
imagine that this provokes some insights
and also some research into this
question because Lithuania has been such
a place of melding and and uh you know
things coming together so tell me a
little bit about what your insights
about how the church deals with yeah so
a lot of people don't know where
Lithuania is even on the map um so if
you're looking at Eastern Europe and
then your eye kind of goes up towards
the top that where it is up towards the
top right on the Baltic Sea right across
the Baltic Sea from Sweden it's next to
belus it's next to Poland it's next to
lvia um and a little piece next to
Russia so if you think about that on the
map that's actually a really important
part of what we're talking
about when Christianity splits um you
know in the 11th century give or take uh
eventually you know Eastern Europe
becomes Orthodox later on largely
speaking although there's already some
some of that going on by the time the
split happens and if you look at where
the border is
between Orthodox East and Catholic West
it basically runs right there that's
exactly the place where the border is um
and Lithuania is interesting in that
regard now of course it's Catholic now
but it was also the very last Pagan
nation in Europe uh it did not become
christianized until the very end of the
14th century who um and yeah so that's
pretty recent relatively speaking
and so uh The Encounter of Christianity
with paganism I mean most of us who were
know anything about church history we
think about the encounter of
Christianity with paganism but we think
about it a thousand years before that
right so it's it's all very nicely in
the past it's all very nicely in the
books all of that has been worked
through you know we don't really even
see the lines that much uh you know
unless someone's looking for them
especially trying to undermine
Christianity let's say um but with
Lithuania it's very much more recent and
um just a few hundred years in the past
and uh even when Catholicism becomes the
national religion there's pockets of
paganism that exist for a while and and
this is the thing that I really want to
talk about today uh there's a lot of
indications of the way that Christians
dealt with paganism and the way that
Orthodox Christians dealt with being in
what was a Catholic majority country so
when that christianization began to
happen in the late 14th century Orthodox
Christianity was already there
Catholicism was of course already there
so you get these two Christian
Traditions kind of competing in the same
space for the hearts of
pagans um but also simply living with
them and being married to them and you
know doing life with them right um so uh
it it forms a really interesting place
to look at this question but I you know
before we get into that too deeply I
want to just actually talk a little bit
about the backstory of Christianity with
regards to dealing with other religions
because if we don't know that then
um what I'm going to talk about in
Lithuania might seem weird uh you know
it might seem surprising or you know
let's let's sweep that under the rug
kind of thing but actually it's it's
normal it's pretty normal in fact right
so you know beginning with with the
Bible
itself uh just in the Old Testament for
instance you get uh The Encounter of the
people of Israel with with the Pagan
religions of the ancient near easts
right uh baale worship of course number
one um also there's a worship of a god
named sheemish who is a Canaanite sun
god um and uh so here's the funny thing
like we all know about the sort of
polemic against Pagan religion in in the
Old Testament you know there's there's
all kinds of mocking of pagan gods and
and all this stuff that we we love you
know it's a lot of fun to read uh we
love The Showdown on Mount Carmel
between uh Elijah and the prophets of ba
you know uh you know with a fire from
heaven and so forth but also what a lot
of people don't know is that some of the
Bale
imagery like the fact that he's the
rider on
clouds that gets used for the son of man
in Daniel yeah and in the gospels when
Christ ascends into heaven right that's
really important it's important to
notice that that it's happening in the
Old Testament especially because people
don't understand for example why we call
the thecus the Queen of Heaven because
they see that as a title for ancient
Pagan goddesses and it's like yes that's
it we took it like and not just took it
but like we showed you what the real
Queen of Heaven is right right I mean
okay so sheemish is another good one
right so one of the um hypostases of
sheemish that was worshiped actually in
jerus in Pagan
Jerusalem you know was called sheemish
Sedaka um so teda or tedak it means
Justice or righteousness and so it's the
son sheemish means son like the sun in
the sky the son of son of righteousness
or son of Justice well this gets used in
Malachi to refer to the son of
righteousness who Rises with healing in
his wings and then in the Orthodox
church we use that same phrase son of
righteousness in our Nativity AP potian
to talk about Christ who gets worshiped
by star worshippers who now go on to
worship the real son of righteousness
yeah yeah yeah you know the the the
troparion the Christmas troparion is a
great example of that exactly where we
show how those that worshiped the stars
are now worshiping the maker of the
Stars basically right yeah and and we're
doing it by taking their Pagan language
and applying it to Jesus you know so
it's again it's in Malachi so it's in
the Old Testament so it's nothing new
for Christians it's in the Old Testament
right uh but the New Testament of course
does this stuff too and the there's a
lot of examples we could point to but
but particularly I like to look at St
Paul in the
areopagus where right before that
chapter before that it says he's really
mad because he sees that Athens is full
of
idolatry right so initially you get the
sense of oh okay so when he goes up to
areopagus he's going to let him have it
he's going to be pical Paul right but of
course that's not what happens when he's
on the areopagus instead he takes this
altar to the unknown God and says I'm
here to Proclaim it this unknown God to
you I mean
that altar was a pagan altar that Pagan
sacrifices were offered on I want to
invite you all to the very first
symbolic World Summit over 3 days we
will finally meet in real time in real
space and everyone from this little
corner of the internet will be there to
explore the theme of reclaiming the
cosmic image of course I will be
speaking there will also be Martin Shaw
who is an amazing mythographer father
Steven D young of Lord of spirit Fame
there will be Richard Roland from the
universal history series vper Stamper
Nicholas kotar and Neil de grade that
you've all seen on my channel here and
there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt cor Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from February 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon spings Florida visit
the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information I
will see you
so Wings andies
our that altar was a pagan altar that
Pagan sacrifices were offered
on right it was not some crypto Jewish
altar or something like that this is a
pagan altar but you know even more
interestingly probably a little less
obvious uh he quotes from two Pagan
poets uh so he quotes from EP amenities
of creit who that line in him we live
and move and have our being uh he also
quotes from aratus um who talks who says
you know and we also are are his
offspring well both of these lines are
about
Zeus like this is Zeus
poetry and Paul is saying yeah yeah I'll
I'll take that you know I'll I'll apply
that to the one true God right so he's
he's subsuming it into what he's doing
he doesn't look at it as being sort of
hopelessly polluted yeah um I this is so
important I
mean especially when you look at I mean
the main objection obviously to
Orthodoxy and to Catholicism from
Protestants are often these types of
things where they look at at at the the
the styles of worship or aspects of
worship that they can see in the Pagan
World they see it coming into
Christianity and then they wonder you
know it doesn't mean that well they
don't have the wonder they declare then
that the worship is Pagan but this is
something like even in in terms of the
revelation of the Tabernacle from God
himself you know the structure of the
Tabernacle is this the structure of
every single Pagan temple in oh yeah in
the world a three- tiered structure you
know with like the most holy place where
you would have that usually they would
have the idol there that would be hidden
and they would be revealed on certain on
certain uh in certain feast or whatever
but the structure itself is is a
universal structure and so and so it's
so the way to see it it's like you could
see it in in a bunch of ways which is
that on the one hand the Pagan uh
Traditions are actually twisting the
true faith and now God is twisting it
back towards what towards its
rightful its rightful uh direction or
you could see it that God is able to
cover over our sins right he's like okay
this is what you do I'm gonna take this
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna turn it in
its right direction but either way
whether it's one or the other you know
that seems to be what God is doing all
the time which is saving that which is
lost yeah I mean it says in the Psalms
right that the Earth is the Lords in the
fullness thereof but but sometimes
people when who have this idea of kind
of religious
coutis um they would say the Earth is
Lords and the fullness thereof except
for these parts which are sort of
hopelessly not his anymore you know
don't don't touch that um yeah so this
kind of thing continues right so I gave
just a couple of examples from the Old
and New Testament I could we could talk
for hours about just the Bible um but
but Christians continue doing this so um
of course as an iconographer you know
full well that the tradition of
Byzantine
iconography owes a lot to the tradition
of Egyptian ferial art yeah right like
if you look at the the art that was on
that was related to Egyptian funerals I
mean again these are pagans these are
demon worshippers yeah even even the RO
Roman it's Roman it's exactly it has
that Egyptian aspect to it and then it
also has a a very strong Roman element
for example the the way that Christ his
Blessing hand like would we say that
Christ is blessing like this that's a
Roman sign of address it's a you can see
the Roman Emperor doing it in the first
century on statues and so you know this
is but it's funny because it the
funniest thing about this honestly
Father Andrew is that this the same
person that can look at ancient Pagan
practices and see how Christianity
transformed them towards the worship of
God will like without non-
apologetically have a rock band on stage
in church and like and I realize that
it's like you know using the language of
the culture to and transforming it it
and it's not even transformed usually in
terms of the the rock band on the stage
but it's like the Christians actually
did a very deliberate
theological ad bringing in of these
elements and transforming them like the
way that Roman art for example moves
from paganism to Christianity you can
see it happening you can look at you
know the sensual elements being toned
down you know the different the these
different elements are being toned down
these are played up you know the the use
of the Halo was used for the emperor for
example so now we we we it's a pagan
sign that was there before and so then
we're like no we're going to reserve
this only for the Saints only for Christ
and his mother and so you can see the
transformation happening but it's a it's
not just accidental like it's not just
like it's not just like taking a rock
band and putting it on stage in your
church it's a theological transformation
of the Pagan things into the Christian
world there's a creative engagement
right it's not just sort of adoption
there's an adaptation also happening um
yeah I mean there's some things that you
could point to as being almost adoption
at least initially and then the
adaptation happens later one really
obvious example are uh Christian
calendars so the Julian calendar I mean
it's not named for St
Julius uh you know it's named for the
divinized emperor exactly Emperor the
divinized emperor literally named for
what pagans would have regarded as a
pagan God Julius Caesar is a p is a God
you know from a Roman Pagan point of
view um and it's not just the Julian
calendar I mean the Coptic calendar is
based on Egyptian
paganism um you know now we think of
these as being calendars that belong to
churches yeah but they didn't start
their lives that way um and the churches
did not say let's start with something
brand new and what's funny is they they
didn't really take the Jewish calendar
very much
I mean there there are elements in the
church calendar that are from the Jewish
calendar but the basic idea of a solar
year for instance a 365 or so days um
these are these are pagan things um one
of the probably more obvious ways that
Christians uh dealt with paganism early
on and um you see it in a lot of saints
lives is that Pagan temples get turned
into Christian churches um so the altars
that were you know had had Pagan
sacrifices put on them become altars to
God or sometimes what they'll do is
they'll take the building smash the
altar replace that um and but the
structure is is you know a pagan Temple
like um lots of examples of that the
Parthenon in Athens of course was
actually a Christian Church longer than
it was a pagan Temple but it was a pagan
Temple you know now it's a museum but um
uh you know there's a number of of well
the pantheon in Rome is one of the most
also the the most shining biggest
example that's still at church now yeah
oh yeah yeah so I mean there's there's a
gazillion examples of this of pagan
temples that become Christian churches
and even the Basilica architecture
itself was from Pagan civil architecture
yeah you know um so it wasn't even for
worship it was you know although there's
no such thing as secularism in the
ancient world right uh so civil
architecture is sacred architecture in
the ancient world um another one of my
favorite examples of course is the
classic uh tretis by St basil the great
called the address to young men on the
uses of Greek literature um and
essentially it's his take on how you
read Homer and heat and so forth and he
doesn't say like that's Pagan don't read
it uh but instead he actually says this
is the weird part he says you need to
master this before you can read the
Bible which I mean I Don't Preach that
and I would never counsel anybody with
that here in
2023 but I mean it's a
pretty we do something like that Father
Andrew which is that you know it's like
I actually made the mistake with my kids
at the outset to just like straight up
read the Bible stories to them which
which which was probably not the wisest
thing to do and and I realized that
actually fairy tales are a good ramp
into Bible stories and so we usually do
something like that with our kids is
that our kids know the fairy tales more
than they'll know the Bible story is at
the outset and as they get older you
know like8 nine 10 years old then it's
easier for them to kind of to to to take
in especially those Old Testament
stories that are that are rough at the
outset um and so we see I think we do
something similar with fairy tales that
St basil talks about in terms of the
ancient yeah um another example of this
and this is one that's a little
controversial but I'm gonna at least
mention it um St uh St John of Damascus
he wrote a text called uh the life of
saints barlam and
joa um and a lot of people say that this
is essentially just an adapt of the life
of Gama Buddha Buddha the Buddha um I
don't know if that's true I mean I've
never really studied this closely it may
be that he simply took that story and
told his story in a way that's
reminiscent of it uh who knows I don't
know but it's but but there is a
possibility that there's at least some
kind of influence and that's not even
you know that's not the comfortable
paganism no yeah exactly very far which
is so funny like it's funny we think of
demon worship by Greeks and Romans and
Egyptians is like we can deal with that
but Buddhism like whoa whoa whoa what do
we do with that stuff yeah it's freaky
uh again controversial I'm not saying
that that's where he got it from I I I
don't know but you can read about it on
the internet um uh some other stuff
that's probably a little bit more um
provocative but much harder to just uh
whisk away um So within Germanic
Christianity so this is later right this
you know Germanic peoples get
christianized later in church history um
not until largely like the e8th nth
century and as you're moving on because
it's moving North right yeah um so a a
fun example I like to point out to
people is there is a an object called
the Franks
casket yeah I saw it in the British
museum there it's amazing yes it's most
of it is at the British museum there's
one panel of it that's in France um
although I think they have a copy of
that panel at the British museum so you
can see the sort of the complete thing
yeah Frank's casket is really
interesting so um you know it's made in
8th Century northumbria so that's
Northern England and it's generally
believed to have been made by
mocks okay um and it was based on the
size and shape it's probably a
reliquary we're not certain but but
probably a reliquary yeah you know uh
and it's called a casket but it's it's
it's you know it's it's this little box
yeah yeah it's a yeah yeah uh it's not
like to hold a body but it's the same
shape yeah as what we would put a body
in and that's deliberate because if
you're G to put a put the relics of a
saint in something you would want to put
it in something that looks like a coffin
you know at least that's what most of
Christian history has done yeah so if
you look at the the uh the images on the
Frank's casket um one of them is the
three wise men you know approaching the
Virgin holding Christ and they're
offering their gifts and you're thinking
okay good this is a good strong
Christians image no problem uh but then
you start walking around the casket and
you know figuratively of course because
again it's just a little box uh on on
one side you've got ramulus and Remis
the founders of the Pagan founders of
pagan Rome you know uh being raised the
wol in like Northern England like right
it just shows you that Universal history
thing that we keep helping getting
people back to we should say how many
pagans are there in North Umbria in the
8th Century probably
none it's probably all Christian yeah
exactly yeah so there are Christians
making this thing uh there's at least
one of the panels that people aren't
sure exactly what it is another one is a
battle that takes place in Jerusalem and
then the one if you look at the panel
that has um the three wise men in the
virgin on it and the lord it's actually
there's it's a 5050 panel so on one side
you've got that on the other side you
have whand the
Smith who is this semi divinized
Germanic Smith you know Divine Smith
Figure who makes magical
weapons uh and that often Gods get
Apprentice to so they can become
powerful
like it's it's it clearly and so it's
it's this Pagan image right next to a
Christian image on the but it's it's
it's it's interesting in the the casket
because the Christian image is the image
of the pagans coming to worship Christ
that's what the that's what the image is
yes it is yes it is you know so it's
interesting you know this Northern uh
English thing and so it's got this
Germanic Pagan image but then it also
has stuff from Roman history uh all
together because that's the cultural
soup of Northern English Christianity in
the 8th Century yeah but it's it's but
it's if you listen to some of the
arguments that you've heard when you
were younger like that you heard people
say you could you had these two
arguments one was Christianity is just
syncretism it's all just borrowing from
pagans whatever and then the other one
is Christianity destroyed all the
ancient Cults they went in they broke
everything and they they ruined the
whole Christian world it's like you
can't have those two at the same time
the actual reality is that it's neither
of those yeah that's right it's neither
of those Christianity as Christianity
took hold it integrated the things it
could integrate it it it it it kind of
let fall to the side the things that
couldn't be integrated and it it ended
up with a a world that was based on the
ancient Pagan World in terms of a lot of
the forms but moving using its meaning
pointed towards God and towards Christ
you know yeah yeah another fun thing
from that same period of anglo-saxon
Christianity and I just have to mention
this um because I don't know if
Richard's gonna mention this in your
bolf class you're doing with him but
this was something I came across as I
was doing transl translation work on
bolf um so there's a phrase that shows
up in it uh which is in in Old English
it's Al Walda Al Walda right and a lot
of editors actually um edit this to make
it Al Walda to make it a single word Al
Walda now that single word means all
ruler so it's like pentor right and this
is referring to God it's pretty clearly
referring to God but if you look at the
actual man manuscript it's two separate
words Al and Walda so Walda is ruler UL
means elves oh yeah so it refers to God
as the ruler of
elves um which you know adjust the
translation a little bit you get Lord of
spirits right that's right um so so
that's interesting so that's clearly a
Germanic Pagan reference you know elves
right right elves are just kind of
spirits in Germanic paganism yeah but
again it's an 8th century Christian
writing this yeah um yeah Al Walda um so
okay a couple examples from Norse
Christianity because I'm comfortable
with the with the Germanic stuff um so
in the 13th century there's a church
built in Norway called The hilstad Stave
church the church doesn't exist anymore
but it's doorposts still do and they're
in a museum now uh but they were on a
couple of different churches if you look
at the doorposts they are carved wood
it's beautiful stuff it's really really
astonishing um and it is the legend of
seur and
faf from The volsunga Saga which again
is dramatic paganism um you've got you
know sigard who is this sort of semi
Divine figure you've got rean who is
definitely a Divine figure you've got
faf definitely a Divine figure faf of
course is a dragon uh you
know in the legend you know sigard goes
down and kills faffer because rean wants
him to so they can get the enchanted
gold
and uh then they decide to uh they're
going to eat him because when you eat a
dragon it makes you gives you magical
powers and he actually tastes some of
the juices from the heart and gives him
the ability to understand the language
of birds as it always does as it always
does
um but this was on the front of a church
yeah you know I had someone tell me one
time when I said can you explain this to
me and they said oh well that was
probably to lurin pagans so they they
would see this and they would come in
and and then they and I'm like okay well
number one let's imagine you're a pagan
Norse Pagan you see this and then you go
in and it's clear that this building is
dedicated to worshiping some other God
like is that really going to work on you
and number two there are no pagans in
13th century Norway exactly they're gone
for hundreds of years for for for
several Centuries by hundreds of years
yeah uh and and another example of
course from that time and place U well
not that place but close to that place
Iceland you get the pros which is one of
the major sources of Norse um Pagan
mythology yeah this is written by snor
sterlon who is a Christian again he's
never met a pagan in his life because
his great great great great great great
grandparents all got
baptized uh you know so he we don't have
any uh sources of Norse paganism that
aren't written by Christians yeah and
you see I mean and you can if you look
at the the the closer like closer to the
Mediterranean you see the exact same
thing happening you know you know the
fact that we have boas's text which is a
Christian text written with so much
Pagan subtext and all of these Illusions
to to these to these allegorical figure
the fact that you'll find in the Middle
Ages people still invoking the mus is
you know these are just things that were
part of Christianity and and to try yeah
to try to parse it one way or the other
is is is is just the wrong way to go and
to to say that Christianity just
basically infiltrated or whatever no
this was a conscious thing when you get
to Dante you can see that when Dante
wrote his poem it didn't shock anyone
it's not like everybody was like oh no
look at him he's like meeting all the
it's like he's mixing Christianity and
paganism it was just like oh wow this is
a great you know nice synthesis of what
we pretty much think and we've always
thought we've always believed for the
last you know 800 years or whatever yeah
yeah I mean it's funny like you
mentioned boethus right so his
consolation the philosophy the big major
text uh when Alfred the Great does his
translation into Old English of
eus he adds in bits about uh Giants uh
from Biblical and enoic texts to sort of
expand out that that that stuff so I
mean just talk just think about the
layers in that yeah yeah yeah um okay so
um I I want to fast forward a little bit
um another example of Christian you know
and relatively recent Christian
engagement with paganism uh in Alaska
very famous athabascan Spirit houses
which you can see they're not too far
from
Anchorage um if you ever visit Alaska
worth seeing I mean this is a a pagan
practice of building sort of little
houses over Graves yeah for the spirits
to live in for a while um and you know
the the Saints the Orthodox Saints who
engag with these people in the 18th
century uh let them keep that but sort
of reinterpreted it you know got them
away from creem
you know but reinterpreted this I mean
you can go see this so if you go there
and you see these Spirit houses they
have three bar crosses on them yeah um
you know it's it's really something um
and then another thing I wanted to
mention that probably would would freak
some people out uh the the the numeral
system that we use we commonly call them
Arabic numerals right which okay that
doesn't sound too threatening but
actually they are traditionally called
Hindu Arabic numerals because they are
Hindu in origin and also then really
developed by Muslims so in that by using
those numbers we are using a A system
that was designed in many ways for
numerology and all kinds of stuff like
this uh every day I mean we're all doing
this so it's it's a system that's a
combination in some ways at least how it
got to us of Islam and of course
Hinduism which is essentially a sort of
pagan set of traditions um so that's
that's a lot of fun okay so um so okay
that's Christianity and paganism there's
lots of things more we could say about
that but I wanted to talk about
historical now historical Christian
Orthodox Christian engagement with
non-orthodox Christianity with other
Christians right again we know full well
the pmics we know full well the
anathematization of Heretics I affirm
all of that right but also what's going
on right now it's like it's a little
tricky all of it with the cnid of cality
or whatever I know like it's all in the
air God bless them um yeah yeah so so I
affirm all
that I'm not a
denter um I'm Orthodox but also in our
history um alongside that um so there is
one there's a feast of the martyrs of
Nan um which I can't remember the date
of that right now off the top of my head
and I didn't write it down but the one
of the main figures in that he's often
called St arthus now his Arabic name is
actually
alhar um so where is naan nran is
basically Southwestern Arabian
Peninsula um and the they were
Christians and there was a a sort of a
judaizing king named dun noas who came
in and uh wiped out almost all of them I
mean there were some left after he did
what he did and so they are commemorated
as Mar Martyrs on our on our calendar
like if you're an an Eastern Orthodox
Christian of whatever variety the
martyrs of Nan are on your calendar St
arthus and so
forth so what kind of Christians were
they in
nazran were they byzantines were they
Greeks probably not no it was a it was
they were mostly what we would call
Oriental Orthodox yeah uh but there was
also a significant presence of the
Assyrian Church of the East than
historians um so they're on our calendar
these are actual saints that are on our
calendar and someone someone might say
well you know
um
uh you know martyrdom you know martyrdom
kind of CLE cleans up some of I mean
actually we have saints saying that the
the blood of martyrdom does not wash
away the stain of
heresy and yet these are Martyrs that
are on our calendar yeah right uh
another related figure from this time
and place is he's called St Caleb or St
elban he is the king of axum so anyone
who's been watching your so your channel
for a while knows where is he's a saint
in our in our on our calendar yeah oh
yeah really CA cause he yeah yeah
because he's related as he's sort of a
protector of these nran
Christians um again I mean he's the king
of Ethiopia Ethiopian Kingdom which
makes him and this is late enough that
makes him what we would refer to as
Oriental Orthodox yeah
again he's a saint on our calendar I did
not know that this is amazing
information father yeah yeah um
so uh another example I I would give um
you know St Isaac of Syria yeah not a
martyr not a martyr as far as we know he
dies in in peace um canonically he
belongs the ass what we would recognize
as the Assyrian Church of the East than
historians yeah now I've never heard
that there's anything in his theology or
any of his writing that that is an
historian yeah but his whole life was
spent outside the canonical boundaries
of you know what we would recognize as
the Orthodox Church yeah what would you
do without St Isaac though and his W
can't get rid of St Isaac come on
through his
writings he becomes a saint to the
Orthodox
church right again what do you do with
that yeah um I don't I don't have a
theory for this by the way like some
sort of method by which you decided this
probably the best way to understand it
is that it's not a it's not there's the
rule and then there's the messiness of
the reality right it's like there's the
there's the kind of organic recognition
of Holiness that the church that the
church does and it's like how did it
happen I don't know how it happened but
there it is and it's it's like don't
argue with st Isaac you I dare you to
it's like he's he's such an amazing
Saint yeah and it's been I mean it's
been long enough like there's no there's
no going back on this yeah yeah exactly
yeah you can't kick him out
you
know yeah although there are examples
where we did yeah so uh one example not
talked of about a lot talked about a lot
but there was I can't remember which one
it was now but there was a metropolis in
Greece that some centuries ago
celebrated the Feast of Thomas
aquinus really I mean oh yeah yeah yeah
um in fact I think there are recordings
available of his hymns Orthodox h for
Thomas aquinus um now is that still
happening no it's
not but you know he was another another
example of someone that threw his
writings because there's a whole like
Orthodox history of Engagement with the
writings of Thomas ainus yeah of course
through his writings at least in one
place for a
while he became celebrated as a saint
yeah it did not last and I know there
are some like uh for example there's a a
pilgrimage site uh are Lady of
Walsingham in
England that is recognized by the
Orthodox and that the Orthodox go to on
pilgrimages but that is is from after
the Schism it's like yeah it's got an
orthodox Chapel there yeah exactly uh
that that I think is maintained by an
orthodox
nun you know um so I want to give one
final example before we start talking
about Lithuania um but I just kind of
wanted to set up these patterns that
exist that exist everywhere in church
history there's thousands more we could
probably talk about um so uh a writer
named Lorenzo scupoli is a 16th century
Roman Catholic priest and he wrote a
book called spiritual combat and it's
about I mean it's it's about what it
says on the label yeah uh so um this
this this work became um very
interesting to a lot of Orthodox
Christians and in the a uh 18th century
St Nicodemus of the Holy Mountain you
know
the guy who puts together the rudder um
and the exarion you know and the ortho
Orthodox like the most Orthodox yes yes
people look at him as like super
hardcore you know anti- everything I
don't like yeah uh he takes this work
and edits it a little and puts it out in
Greek I mean this again this is about
16th century Catholic priest right um
and then it gets further reviv IED and
published in Russian by St theun the
Reus wow so St theun you know does even
more with it right so St Nicodemus just
sort of edits a little bit I'm not sure
how extensive the edits were but St
theon's edits were much more extensive
that I know um and then you know there's
even a sort of set of volumes that were
actually put up by consilier press a
long long time ago with titles like
victory in the Unseen Warfare and sort
stuff like this that was a sort of um
lame
man's version of of this you know like
taking it apart and looking at it and
explaining it and so forth right so this
is a Catholic text that's made its way
into the Orthodox church and actually
been handled and promulgated by Saints
Yeah by Saints you know again no one
doubts the Orthodoxy of St Nicodemus no
one dos the Orthodoxy of St the and the
recluse these are significant Saints of
the you know relatively modern period
age yeah that's amazing I mean but I
think in some ways to me at least what
it does is it it it it's I think it it's
there to also keep us humble and to be
careful you know to understand that God
we don't we don't cont we have the
Cannons and we should live by them but
that also God is not in the box that we
think he is God does not you know like
we need God and God does not need you
could say does not need us in the same
way let's say that that that that God is
is is manifesting himself where where he
pleases that's right that's right okay
so let's talk about Lithuania all right
with all that
background um yeah you know everywhere
you go there on uh pretty much every
Catholic church and I've even seen some
of this in some of the Orthodox Churches
although most of the Orthodox Churches
there are very Russian um but uh almost
everywhere you go you see the The Sun
Cross right and um so it's again it's
what it says on the label right it's a
cross with a sun sort of imagery
integrated into it there's lots of
versions of this and sometimes you'll
see a crescent moon at the
bottom which is interesting you know
Orthodox Christians seeing a crescent
moon at the bottom of a cross we largely
might think of okay this is about
conquest of Islam yeah but in in the
Baltic case it's not you know
um the bals are not conquering Islam it
exists there but only it's always been a
minority you know um yeah so it's the
Sun and Moon um you know and and this
cross was a pagan symbol it was
absolutely a pagan symbol and now you
see it on the top of almost every single
Church in
Lithuania um you know there are no
Lithuanian pagans still around although
there are some neopagans but that's a
newer thing yeah um so lping they're
just LARPing anyways God bless them I
think that is true um so um so one
really interesting um bit of material
culture from Pagan Lithuania is
something and I'm know I'm going to
mispronounce this but you probably don't
have a lot of actually you do have some
Lithuanian fans oh you do I met some of
them when I went to Lithuania that's
hilarious in fact when I gave I gave a a
year ago when I gave a talk at a church
in vnus one of the first questions that
someone asked me was do you know
Jonathan
P it's like well he's Canadian he's
Canadian yeah well that means I need to
go to Lithuania I've always wanted to go
oh you totally if you go I will go with
you you to go as your fellow pil let's
do it I think you would find it a very
interesting place to go um so yeah so
there's a figure from Baltic paganism
called the uh
dvis and what that word means literally
is
godmaker uh so a godmaker is a Carver of
religious images oh there you
goh so that's that's what that is uh and
so back in the day you know this guy
would have been essentially carving
idols H right um idols and also then
used in actual uh Pagan worship but then
also essentially Pagan
icons that are used for devotional
purposes the house house idols and
things like that right right right and
um so these are these traditionally were
placed up on top of wooden
poles um and so this is called I'm I
know I'm going to get this wrong too uh
coplet stus a coplet stus which means
Chapel pillar now is sort of the idea so
you can see that word coplet is related
part that piece coplet is related to the
word Chapel um and so it would be a
wooden pole and then on top of it you
would have this this carved um statue
and then there would usually be a roof
over top of it um and then often The Sun
Cross on top yeah right um
so this uh survives but now if you find
one of these things and they're actually
all over Lithuania like you could just
be driving along and just see one by the
side of the road often in the middle of
nowhere you know um if you see one now
you're not going to find uh dvas or
perkunas you know who are these these
Baltic Gods you're not going to find
them on the c stus um you're gonna see
most often there's a figure called rupen
Tois so rupen Tois is is Christ um as
he's going to to his passion so there's
sort of two different poses you'll see
him like with his face and his hands
like this often called the pensive
Christ or you sometimes see him standing
and bound you know his hands are bound
yeah so this is rupen Tois often called
the Pence of Christ that's the most
Russian tradition of that too of like in
some of the remote places of Russia they
have this whole carving tradition with
that figure very important where do you
think they got it yeah yeah it's
probably the same it's from there it's
from the baltics um and of course it
spreads into it's throughout the former
polish Lithuanian Commonwealth so you've
got it in Poland as well they've got it
in Belarus they've got it in
Ukraine um yeah um often then you'll see
uh if you don't have rup and to yellis
there you'll see um the the Virgin
Mary uh you'll see lots of saints
especially St George uh is pretty
popular um also of course the Catholic
St kmir uh who is the the Catholic
patron of of Lithuania not an Orthodox
Saint but he's he's their big Saint uh
he's buried there in their National
Cathedral um so related to that you'll
also see again the same the Carver the
wood carver called
aisus which means crossmaker there you
go uh and you know the the Lithuanian
standing crosses are basically an
extension of this uh
Deus practice that's the name of the
person but I don't remember what the
name of the practice itself is but it's
an extension of that but it's but
obviously focusing on the cross itself
right and they can be incredibly ornate
yeah you know I just made one by the way
oh really yeah uh three meter like nine
foot cross with a single mass that that
goes into the ground and and it's know
goes into three and there's Mother of
God and St John the Sun and the Moon at
the top and a little roof at the at the
top yeah a massive project yeah yeah uh
and so sometimes there will be little
statues embedded right at the the point
where the cross pieces meet usually
Christ again often usually the rup to
yellis uh but it can be other figures
sometimes too and again you'll see these
by the side of the
road uh they will be placed there
sometimes in commemoration of an event
or of of people um a lot of Pious people
just put them in their yard like so you
there be there 10 15 foot tall cross in
the front
yard you know um and a lot of churches
have them in the churchyard yeah as well
um so and then of course the the classic
you know place where people might have
seen these is the hill of crosses where
there's uh hundreds of thousands of them
and um there's actually a legal limit on
the size of a cross you're allowed to
place there which is nine
meters that's amazing
if you're gonna if when we go to
Lithuania decide you want to put a cross
there just be aware that Li
me I love it it's hilarious because it's
like in North America you would expect
it to be like five feet or something
something like some ridiculous small
thing it's like well there is a legal
limit but you know nine meters don't go
beyond that these things Tower over you
I mean it envelops you it envelops you
yeah and you know this is in many ways
this is a spiritual heart of this
country and it's not just Roman
Catholics that go there although
obviously mostly Catholics you can go
there and you can see Orthodox crosses
there um and and Protestants go there as
well you know and um often you see PE
writing on many of them it's usually
lists of names of people that they want
to pray for and most of the writing of
course is in Lithuanian but you can see
many languages many many languages from
all over the world people that have made
their pilgrimage brought their cross
there um so I mean it's largely regarded
as a kind of a Catholic place of
pilgrimage but orthodox Christians go
there I've been there twice now myself I
placed a cross there both times and
brought you know two of my children with
me they placed a cross there with the
names that they wanted to pray for on
there you know what is the this hill
what is the story about the hill like
why why do people go there what's the
what's the legend or the story related
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
different origin stories uh for the hill
of crosses but the one that I think is
the truest
one um is
uh so the hill of crosses seems to have
Arisen during the Russian imperial
period um that's the earliest references
to it so you're talking like early 19th
century possibly um and um the the there
is a tradition that uh there was a man
who had a a a daughter who was very very
ill and so he was at her bedside every
night praying to God to please heal her
and then finally um after a long time of
this uh the Virgin Mary appears to him
and says
um take up your cross and bring it to
the place that I'll show you and so this
man becomes
aisus and he fashion this wooden cross
and he starts carrying it you know and
it's it's a long distance and then
finally she appears to him again and
says this is the place and so now
Lithuania has no mountains so actually
the word
um uh Kus for for m mountain is just
means a hill yeah uh you know so they'll
use the same word like they would use
Kus to refer to the mountains that we
have here in North America but but they
know full well that there's no
comparison between them you know um so
it's a hill and it's kind of a long hill
so it's spread out you know o over a
ways and has a couple of Peaks to it um
and so he places the cross in this hill
and then he begins the walk back home
and then when he he's reaching his where
his home is uh two people come running
out of the house to uh to greet him one
is his wife and one is his healed
daughter who now can not only stand but
run you know and so so then it the
tradition then grows that you if you're
going to go there you bring a cross and
it can be I mean people bring crosses
that are like this uh everything from
this to you know N9
meters smaller ones people will hang
from bigger ones so you can find crosses
that have like hundreds of crosses
hanging from them uh leaning up against
them I mean it's just it's just a mess
of crosses but a beautiful mess yeah um
and then you know it gets especially
during the Soviet period the Soviets of
course hated this place so they would
bulldoze it down or light it on fire um
and they would wipe it all out and then
overnight it starts growing back because
people just come and they Place their
cross and they pray their prayers um you
know some place the cross there because
they're praying for um someone who's ill
or praying for someone who has died um
some place it because of a happy
occasion like the first time I went for
instance there's a woman who's bringing
along her her boy and says come on let
me show you the place where I put the
cross when you were
baptized you know so so that kind of
thing um again it's a place of sort of
universal Christian pilgrimage
they don't check your religious ID card
at the
door um you
know um so yeah um another one that's
probably a little bit controversial from
Lithuanian history and and people might
not realize it's Lithuanian history uh
is the Orthodox St Peter
moila so St Peter moila is the
Metropolitan of
Kiev um and during uh after the the you
know the loss of the churches to the to
the union
um so Kev of course in Ukraine but the
grand duy of Lithuania includes most of
buus and Ukraine at that point in
history and at that point is actually
then part of the the uh the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth right so St
Peter moila a lot of people pointed him
and say he's a
latinized Latin textbooks he's a
latinized saint so that means you have
to deal with what he did we can critique
it but um there's actually been you know
so some Scholars of course like um
father George fosi really critiques him
and says this is a latinization and so
on and so forth but there's other
scholarship that you can read now that
essentially says well St Peter was
actually trying to do with Catholic
theology that was around him and that he
had to deal with because he's living in
it he was trying to do with that like
the early church fathers were doing with
Pagan
philosophy so
I'm I'm not an expert to tell you what
the truth of the matter is but I mean
this is another way of interpreting him
and it's worth kind of exploration so
that's actually a theological engagement
it's not just sort of material culture
stuff it's actually like language and
and so forth you know um so that's a
really he's a really interesting figure
um I want to finish up by talking about
a couple of icons but before I do that
there's a significant practice that I
want to mention so
in Lithuania there is a two-day holiday
called valines uh so Venus um from the
word uh I think it's velis which means
Soul so Venus is November 1 and 2
They're All Souls basically exactly it's
the the Feast of All Saints and All
Souls and uh in the Catholic
tradition and the practice in Lithuania
on those days is to visit the graves of
your departed loved ones so if you go to
Lithuanian cemeteries they're not like
most cemeteries in North America where
it's just rope on row of stones and
they've hired somebody to mow the lawn
and there might be flowers that people
put that die you know whatever um you
know there's sometimes there's more to
that more than that but I mean most
cemeteries in the US yeah I don't know
about Canada but most the they're pretty
bare yeah in Lithuania every single
grave plot is outlined in either cement
or Stones so they're like little or or
sometimes a fence yeah um and they're
all like flower gardens and they're
immaculately taken care of and it's not
because there's some Gardener can you
imagine how much work that would be yeah
you know they're that way because the
family takes care of
them um I went to the cemetery where my
ancestors are
buried and I went to the grave and we
found the grave actually of my family
which was an astonishing moment you know
um and it's it was immaculately taken
care of everything was in perfect Order
Perfect order right so so lithuanians
visit the graves of their relatives
twice a year once on the day that is the
an the anniversary of the death and then
also at V
vainus right and particularly at vainus
they will bring candles and place them
there and so if you go to cemeteries in
Lithuania at night during villain
it's almost like another city with all
the candles I mean it's just you can see
an outline of the cemetery in
candles it's just completely filled in
with these little flickering
Flames um so Orthodox Christians do this
in Lithuania on those
days even though those that's not the
Orthodox Feast of All Souls of The
Departed but they do it they visit the
graves of their relatives they put the
candles there are specific prayers to be
prayed uh when you go there now it's
interesting there's a sort of Orthodox
adaptation that's occurred so the
Saturday before the Feast of St
Demetrius at the sliki is traditionally
a Saturday of souls right we think of
usually the ones in Lent but or around
lent but but that's also a Saturday of
souls traditionally in the Orthodox
Church the Saturday before October 26th
right so of course most most Orthodox
Christians the are on the old calendar
so that would mean that it's about
November 8th or whatever is is when that
or actually it's a Saturday before
November 8th which sometimes would kind
of coincide with villainous right right
right you know because of course
Catholics are on the new calendar um so
what they do is they visit the
cemeteries on vainus and then on that
Saturday that's usually right after they
go to church and they pray for the
Departed in church so they created this
hybrid practice you know again they're
just they're they're taking something
from Catholic practice and they're
engaging in it themselves
um and there are you talk to to
Lithuanian Christians and and a lot of
them will say now I don't know if the
truth of this a lot of them will say oh
villainous actually is is pre-christian
yeah um which is believable you know
yeah totally believable um so yeah so
they make this kind of annual pilgrimage
um to the graves of their family and
again it's not because it's a feast day
on the Orthodox calendar it's it's now
those those are public holidays in
Lithuania
one of the advantages of what is at
least still officially a Christian
Nation um they have religious freedom
but you also get November 1st and second
off from work in school you also get you
know August 15th off you get you know uh
SE uh uh June
204th you know like in fact uh St John's
day in June is a it's called yonis is a
huge holiday there huge huge holiday
right um and a fun little thing I was
talking one of my Lithuanian friends one
time because we had started to see uh
fireflies in our yard I don't know if
you have them where where you are yeah
um and I asked him I said do you have
fireflies in Lithuania he said oh yeah
we have fireflies we call them yon
Vialis I was like what does yon Vialis
means he says it means St John's bug so
they literally name the fireflies after
the Forerunner there in
Lithuania um probably because of the
probably because of the summer Feast of
year June 24th that's right right
exactly exactly okay so I wanna I want
to finish up with with Lithuania talk
about two different icons um one that a
lot of people probably know about and I
think we talked about when I was with
you uh with Richard when we talked about
this documentary The Wolf from the cross
before and that's our lady of the Gate
of the Dawn I won't go into a lot of
detail because we talked about it before
but it's worth noting that this icon
which is uh on above a gate in vilus the
capital uh
there's some possibility that it might
have an orthodox origin there's some
possibility that it might have spent
some time in Orthodox Churches but
there's no good evidence for that uh
even if all of that is true for most of
its life it's been in a Catholic Chapel
in fact one of the times I went to see
it in my most recent trip Mass was going
on right in front of it when I went
there right um this is the national icon
of Lithuania Our Lady of the Gate of the
Dawn and it's it's the theot too says
she's depicted in Revelation chapter 12
clothed in the Sun the moon under her
feet a crown of 12 stars like that's
that's the image right and um a copy of
this icon was very likely given to St
Sarah from absar off and is the famous
icon in front of which he prayed and in
front of which he died yeah you know
given to him probably in Kiev because
veneration of this icon spread
throughout you know the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth Grand D of
Lithuania um you know Orthodox
Christians
make pilgrimage to that icon venerate
that icon it has a feast day on the
Orthodox
calendar this as far as anyone has ever
known Catholic icon is celebrated on the
day after
Nativity and local Orthodox Christians
including the bishop including clergy go
and pray on malban in front of this icon
on the day after Christmas in this
Catholic Chapel yeah right and it is you
know it's it's this is the the calendar
of the Russian Orthodox church has this
icon on it um lesser known and this is
one of the visits I made in my most
recent stop in Lithuania so there is a
monastery near Kus so Kus is sort of the
Second City of Lithuania um it's in the
center of the country it was for a Time
the capital During the interwar period
because vilus was held by the Polish uh
during that period and so the capital
gets moved to konus and uh second
largest city so there's a monastery near
konus was called pus Monastery so pus
was uh built if I as I recall correctly
in the E either the 16th or 17th
century um and it was built as a
Catholic Monastery right so it's built
by Catholics for Catholics and um you
know this is the uh the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth period and um so
Catholicism is the official state
religion of the whole Commonwealth of
course there's still Orthodox minority a
significant Orthodox minority especially
if you look at the areas that are now
Ukraine and belus but even still in
Lithuania proper there were some
Orthodox so pis Monastery one of the
things that's um made for this Monastery
is an icon of the Virgin
Mary um and so it's called Our Lady of
pus right and if you look at it uh it's
it's painted probably by an Italian it
seems to have been a gift from the
pope um if you look at it it's a very
Western sort of Renaissance
depiction um you know it's not it's not
sensual at all
right it's actually very restrained you
know um there's a sort of a a circle of
roses in the icons so I mean it's not a
Byzantine icon at all like a circle of
roses like if you put that on an icon
you know that would get returned
probably you know um and so it's
definitely a very Western depiction
pagent by Italian gift from the pope for
this Catholic Monastery okay and it's
venerated you know uh Miracles start to
be associated with this
icon so in the late 18th century the
partition of the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth is complete with a third
partition and Lithuania becomes part of
the Russian Empire okay so um the
Russian Empire I'll just say was not
kind to Lithuania and in many cases
engaged in religious
persecution um which if you're
interested in that episode four which
has not yet been made but episode four
of the wolf from the cross is going to
be talking about Lithuanian and the
Russian Empire um it's not be a
comfortable story for a lot of people
it's just the reality the Russian Empire
engaged in in religious persecution of
non-orthodox
um and so one of the things that
happened was churches and even
monasteries that belong to the Catholic
Church were taken and given to the
Orthodox right and picis Monastery is
one of those places so in the um I think
it was in the 19th century um it becomes
a cath an orthodox
Monastery and and um I should mention by
the way uh you know the architecture and
the interior Decor of this Monastery is
absolutely astonishingly beautiful it's
really something uh very different from
a lot of Western churches definitely
different from Eastern churches but it's
really really worth looking
up anyway um so so what do they do with
this icon that's like the alter piece
you know so it's a major very prominent
image in this church what do they do
with this icon they say oh look at this
Ian thing let's get this out of here get
some good Russian iconography in here
you know no they keep it yeah and they
venerate it and they take the Catholic
feast day of the icon and put it on the
rashed
calendar so it becomes a feast of the
Orthodox Church of this miracle working
Catholic
icon Orthodox Christians make pilgrimage
to it they especially would go on the
dorm Mission um the feast day is July
15 it remains on the Russian Orthodox
calendar if you go there now it is once
again a Catholic
Monastery um and uh so it was given back
in when Lithuania became independent in
195 I think it was uh from the Russian
Empire a lot of churches that have been
taken from the Catholics were were given
back to them you know and um so it
reverts to being a Catholic
Monastery and um so here's a couple fun
details not only do Orthodox Christians
continue to make pilgrimage to this
Catholic Monastery to venerate this
wonderwork icon that has a completely
Catholic origin but was sort of Orthodox
for a
while the the Orthodox Church maintains
the Feast of Icon even though the
Catholics have moved it so what you're
looking at when you see the July 15th
Feast is the old Catholic feast day
maintained by the Orthodox Church even
now right um yeah so so this is still
like you can look this up the Russians
call it
PESA
PESA which I'm sure I'm probably
mispronouncing but it's probably pretty
close but the name of the monastery is
pus you know um and
so again this is an example
of uh this sort of Horus border yeah
right it's you know one could look at
that and say ah syncretism you know but
what's happening is simply as we looked
at the tradition of the church yeah the
Bible early Christianity and so forth um
so right so so those are just some
examples that I I could point out I mean
there's there's a number of other things
that we could mention like burial
practices for instance um Orthodox
burials in Lithuania tends to rather
than having the cross at the foot which
is sort of the Orthodox tradition they
often will put the at the head which is
you know in the west um and um you know
there there's other things you could
mention like that um yeah so you know in
our life I mean it's like in our life
this is at least for my life this is
true you know I to be honest like you
know you're not going to take take my
Christmas songs away from me I don't
know what to tell you it's like I love
Western Christmas songs I think they're
beautiful I think they're wonderful I
wouldn't want them sung in liturgy but
you're not going to completely take them
away from me like you will hear them in
my house and we will sing them and we
will love them you know so there's some
of that all over the place I think yeah
I mean like just like let's just look at
Orthodox Christianity here in the west
uh we've taken a whole bunch of stuff
from other
Christians largely without um a lot of
analysis
in many cases right so Sunday school I
mean Sunday I thought exactly Sunday
Sunday school is probably the most
obvious um uh seminaries I mean you know
now seminaries existed in Orthodox
history before it ever made it to here
but seminaries are not the ancient
Christian
tradition like there are other ways of
training clergy um you know you
mentioned Christmas carols I mean that's
a really really good example Christmas
carols and you know it's great you know
many many Orthodox in the west will sing
the Christmas carols from wherever their
tradition is from um but I mean you can
still going to hear Joy to the World and
Silent Night and you know this stuff
that's that's just the English language
Christmas Carol reparatory you know yeah
um another great example I think of this
um is uh the fact that we have Parish
membership yeah yeah that's not a thing
in MO mostly on the other side of the
Atlantic uh in Orthodox Church Parish
councils all that stuff bearish councils
are another big example of that um and
you know something that's dear near and
dear to both you and me media yeah yeah
using using especially modern media for
orthodox purposes the Catholics and the
Protestants were there long long before
us right um so all right so I mean like
what what what's the takeaway from all
of this stuff um yeah it doesn't mean
that anything goes I think it's
important to be careful it's like we're
not all saying that all right so then
you know whatever like it all it's all
it's all but it it's really about
hierarchy you know it's usually just a
an understanding of hierarchy is that we
have we have the the main traditions we
have the Cannons we have all of these
things which guide us and then we have
to understand that those are not like a
machine they're not like a computer that
runs and that that tabulates it's a it's
an organic reality that's connected to
the world and and there's room for God
to act within that in ways that surprise
us
yeah I mean you know like so like why
does the church do this how does the
church do this um the first question I
think is easier to answer than the
second one but I I should say it's not
about putting a stamp of approval on
non-orthodox
religion obviously not the same Old
Testament that uh you know pokes fun at
the gods of the Nations also steals
their
stuff you know uh right so so it's not
about putting a stamp of approval it's
not right um it also doesn't happen
without creative engagement like there
are always changes made to the work to
make it conform to Orthodox Christianity
and it can be maybe a little
uncomfortable to see that in process
yeah it's not clean it's not a clean
thing it's messy process and and you
know I've I've studied this and I intend
to study this a lot longer but I I
haven't found like a theory of it no
like this is how you do that well or
correctly you know but it's it's still a
thing it's it's happening right um so
like the why of it right um it's
because whatever is being adopted and
adapted I think it's important to put
those two words together in this adopted
and adapted it was seen as being for the
Salvation of
Christians like it's not about like oh I
want to adulterate my Pure or or oh oh
I'm some kind of you know liberal ACC
humanist um that's not what's going
on that's that's not what's going on um
it's it's like oh here's something that
we can use for the Salvation of people
um and like I I I said this in the most
recent episode of wolf and Lacrosse um
an icon of the
theotokos is an icon of the theotokos
yeah like it is what it is like it might
have been made by somebody that I would
regard as as a
heretic uh it might have spent all of
its life in the hands of people who are
not Orthodox Christians but it still is
what it is yeah and the church is able
to recognize that and does recognize
that right um you know you know it's
funny we have this saying now from the
zeit guys love is love now they don't
mean by that what I'm about to say but
love is love which means that someone
who's actually engaging in Acts of Love
Real Love Christian love is doing it
even if that person is not a member of
the right church that's right it it is
real all truth is God's truth I mean St
Justin Martyr very famously talks about
the the speros logos right the the logos
and Seed form that he sees everywhere I
mean he's looking at Pagan philosophy
and we should remember that Pagan
philosophers are not just not a bunch of
Ivy Tower academic who never Sully
themselves with religion these are
actual demon worshippers yeah well also
I mean it it's like read the read play
folks it's there's stuff in Plato that
you would blush at and so yeah you know
so the idea that we can read it as
Christians and we can take the good and
let leave the bad fall to the Wayside is
something the Christians did from the
very beginning and that we continue to
do through a whole history yeah I mean
this is you know like this is what St
basil says in that text that I mentioned
earlier he says be like to be right this
is the original be the be uh you know go
to the Pagan flower take what you need
and leave the rest that's that's what he
saids yeah um you know he doesn't say
you know Don't Go Near that right and
and he's living in a time when paganism
is on the Wayne he doesn't have to do
that he he's not he's not feeling
pressure from the society yeah exactly
you know yeah he's on the winning side
at that point yeah yeah late fourth Cent
I mean he's yeah they're they're they're
winning you know um so I I think that
you know as if we look at this question
of creative engagement um I believe that
particularly at this time of
polarization that we have so much of
that where it's really about lining up
all the guns and Blasting the other side
which I mean pmic is sometimes
appropriate the church fathers do it
especially when someone is attacking or
trying to undermine the
church they I've never seen them do it
simply because someone who has a
wrong belief or wrong practice just
exists you know it's really about it's
it's a defensive thing to
do they're not being defensive in the
sense that we talk about it now but
they're being Defenders but they're
actually defending against actual
attacks they're not um they're not
looking for enemies they're not looking
for people to debate they're they're
actually defending against Real attacks
right um and and here's the thing I
believe that if we can if we can begin
to understand this creative engagement
better um not only can we do it
ourselves and God willing do it well
probably with some stumbles along the
way like we're going to make some
mistakes uh but we can make them in good
faith but I think that this in many ways
is a way forward out of the our
polarizing it's a
demonic Spirit actually the spirit of
polarization it's a way forward out of
that because it's actually about
humility and demons can't do
humility um and and it's not I would
also say it's not just something that oh
this is a good idea for now here in
2023 I think it's pretty clear this is
what the church has always done because
the Earth is the Lord's and the fullness
thereof or as St Paul said you know
whatever things are good whatever things
are true whatever things are honest
whatever things are beautiful think on
these things he didn't say whatever
things are in this box that I'm
presenting you with it's whatever things
and he himself did this he took some of
these whatever things and and made use
of them you know so the same guy who
said don't worship Zeus also took Zeus
poetry and applied it to God it to God
that's
right so well thanks Father Andrew this
is amazing I mean you know I'm gonna
relisten to this just for all the
examples there's so such wonderful
examples that that can you help us see
just to what extent this has been
happening and and you're really also
bolstering the you know what Richard and
I's Universal history position is which
is that like you said this is something
the Christians have always done that
even the Old Testament is already
happening um and so we just need to yeah
humility move forward with humility and
also attention you know and prayer so
thanks Father Andrew this has been
wonderful and also and good luck I good
luck with the continuation of the the
wolf and the cross can't wait to see all
that thank you it's a big it's a big
project bigger than I think we realized
but we decided we wanted it to be big uh
so we're just going for it I mean it's
going to be Nine episodes of two to
three hours each so uh we just released
episode three so as I like to say at the
end of each episode we've got a lot more
stories to tell all right thanks Father
Andrew thank
[Music]
you